so it's treason then
or at least that's what a lot of people
are worried about people are rightfully
upset about the trump campaign and the
trump administration's attempts to
effectively overthrow the results of the
2020 election
so the question is and i never thought
i'd be asking this question
did people commit sedition and treason
when they stormed the capital on january
6th and more importantly
did some of our elected politicians
actually commit sedition and treason and
if they did
can they be expelled from congress
[Music]
sponsored by skillshare hey legal eagles
it's time to think like a national
security lawyer and welcome to my new
office with one of those
incredibly practical outward-facing
desks but it does allow me to do this
which adds quite a lot of gravitas to
whatever i'm going to say it's legal
eagle now with seven percent more
gravitas
but today we're talking about sedition
and treason
americans are trying to find the right
words to convey
just how desperate the trump
administration's efforts are to hold on
to power
and they've generally landed on the
concepts of treason and sedition
but do they fit well let's start with
what is
treason the early americans were men and
women who actually committed treason
against the english crown
that's actually how this country was
founded so they were bound to have a
pretty limited view of what constituted
an offense against the state
in their experience kings used treason
charges to silence their political
opponents and to punish their enemies
so they defined treason quite narrowly
treason is in fact the only crime
described in the constitution
treason against the united states shall
consist only in levying war against them
or in adhering to their enemies giving
them aid and comfort
no person shall be convicted of treason
unless on the testimony of two witnesses
of the same overt act
or on confession in open court this
comes from the english definition of
treason in the 14th century
edward iii's judges expanded the common
law concept of treason to cover just
about anything the king
didn't like for example if a person went
hunting on the king's force without
permission
this was treason rather than trespass
that's a crime
but that probably shouldn't be treason
therefore the
english aristocracy compelled edward iii
to agree to an act of parliament that
restricted the definition of treason to
a direct offense against the king or his
family such as acts of violence loving
war against england and
giving aid and comfort to the king's
enemies in the english realm or
elsewhere
and that's where we derive the
definition of treason in the u.s
constitution
either leving war against the united
states or adhering to the enemies of the
united states and giving them aid and
comfort
which repeats an interesting legal
principle the founders were
simultaneously disgusted by the monarchy
but also guided by english legal
principles which takes us to the affair
of
aaron burr there actually haven't been
that many prosecutions against
politicians for committing treason
probably for good reason but the most
prominent politician to be tried for
treason against the united states is
probably aaron burf former vice
president and the man who killed
alexander hamilton in a duel
after burr killed hamilton the political
class basically shunned burr
but he wasn't willing to wait for it so
burr reached out to great britain to
offer his help
if they felt like annexing the western
united states the english royalty more
or less ignored burst so he went on a
recruiting trip to blenner hassett
island
think of this as the mar-a-lago of the
ohio river
where he got financial backing from a
wealthy irish immigrant and burr went to
new orleans and enlisted the help of
basically rich guys and ex-politicians
the plot seemed to involve annexing
parts of mexico and louisiana and
convincing other states to secede and
start a new country
but burr wasn't just talking trash his
co-conspirator was general james
wilkinson
basically the mike flynn of the 19th
century wilkinson was the highest
ranking general in the army
and like flynn wilkinson was a secret
agent for a foreign government
in his case spain but unlike flynn
nobody knew about wilkinson's treachery
at the time wilkinson was still on
active duty in command of western
soldiers
but after a year of planning wilkinson
backed out and alerted president
jefferson
burr left blenner hassett island with
fewer than 100 supporters and tried to
escape
he was eventually caught and tried for
treason but the trial was america's
first
trial of the century burr was defended
by two ex-attorneys general just think
of them as the bill barr
and jeff sessions of the time and those
lawyers argue that the definition of
treason required evidence of an overt
act by the defendant in furtherance of
levying war against the united states
and chief justice marshall agreed with
this interpretation he ruled that
burr had a first amendment right to
voice his opposition to the government
to the president and to the very concept
of the united states but
marshall's definition of overt action
was very narrow quote
there must be an actual assembling of
men for the treasonable purpose to
constitute a levying of war in his mind
talk without assembling of men willing
to levy war was not actually treason and
there was no question that burr
loved to talk about schemes to take down
the us and get back at his political
rivals
there was little doubt that burr had
rallied with volunteers and businessmen
who
would back his venture however burr
wasn't physically present on
blenderhazard island when his volunteers
gathered with weapons and
justice marshall had already told the
jury that they couldn't consider any
actions of war that occurred outside of
blender hassett island
the prosecution could not convince the
jury to hold burr responsible for an
overt act
taking up arms against america the jury
found him
not guilty burr's goals were still murky
to this day largely because burr said
different things to different people
on one day he was trying to colonize
part of louisiana the next he was trying
to convince western settlers to revolt
against the united states and the day
after that he was hoping to wrangle
texas away from spain
and while the elements of treason can
include the breach of allegiance these
actions were not unanimously considered
treason since
plotting against spain was not exactly a
betrayal of allegiance to the united
states
and it wasn't entirely clear that
encouraging the states to engage in
another revolution was illegal in 1805
either but the burr prosecution was the
exception rather than the rule there
have been fewer than 30 treason charges
since the constitution was ratified in
1789.
the people who conspired with john
wilkes booth to kill president lincoln
were charged with traitorous murder and
attempted murder
people were charged with treason for
defecting to nazi germany during world
war
ii or aiding and abetting the japanese
during the same period
so the question is does anything that
president trump or his surrogates
have said or done rise to the level of
treason
well in a legal sense almost certainly
not
now arguably the closest president trump
has ever come to treason would be in
arguably collaborating with a foreign
government to undermine the united
states through interfering with an
election
and while welcoming and utilizing the
resources of a foreign government
in one's own election is a lot of things
it's probably not levying war and it's
probably not treason
and with respect to the things that the
president and the president's campaign
have tried to do with respect to undoing
the results of the 2020 election through
petitioning the courts most of what they
have done explicitly seeks to use the
force of the united states
whether that use of force is legitimate
or not so he isn't levying war against
the united states he's actually
advocating for the use of
the implements of the united states
itself so no matter how badly you may
think he has acted in that context and
you'd probably be right that he's acted
pretty poorly
again that's not levying war against the
united states
so it's not treason then
but what about sedition america's second
president john adams signed the sedition
act in 1798.
the sedition act made it a crime for
american citizens to quote
print utter or publish any false
scandalous or malicious writing
about the government the sedition act
was pretty obviously unconstitutional
because it trampled on the first
amendment right to freedom of speech
but adams and his federalist party went
full steam ahead with prosecutions
charging dozens of newspaper editors
with sedition
now obviously president trump would have
loved this law since it gave him the
ability to jail reporters which he has
many times advocated for but the
americans of
1800 however did not love the sedition
act and punished the federalists by
electing thomas jefferson to the
presidency
the original sedition act expired in
1801 and the crime of sedition has been
severely limited in the modern era
current laws on sedition were passed in
1940. a second sedition law punishes
anyone who advocates for the overthrow
of the federal government by
force now the main distinction between
sedition and treason is that treason
requires levying or waging war
sedition can be language or conduct that
incites people to destroy or overthrow
or attack the government the supreme
court upheld the constitutionality of
the sedition laws but
they're construed very narrowly to
prohibit the government from attacking
purely political speech
as currently interpreted sedition does
not destroy the first amendment's
guarantee of freedom of speech
like treason sedition requires actively
plotting to take up arms against the
united states
simply talking about it on parlor is not
enough
but if the parlor patriots meet up and
plot to kill a governor or assassinate
an incoming president
they could be charged with sedition and
as the statute is currently interpreted
you actually have to plot to use
force against the united states and
proving sedition is harder than you
might think
for example in 2014 a christian focus
group known as the
hutteri held military training exercises
in michigan
and amassed lots and lots of weapons
they called themselves warriors for
jesus and were found in possession of
tear gas night vision goggles a dagger
a sword manuals on bomb making books by
hitler race war books and a bunch of
guns
the fbi spent a year infiltrating the
group and eventually charged them with
plotting to kill a police officer and
ambush several more officers at a
funeral
but a federal judge acquitted all of
them because they were engaged in
political speech
the judge said that quote there was
something fishy going on but since
something fishy isn't illegal the
charges were dismissed
the huttery argued that their training
exercises were just some dudes playing
with guns in the woods
as one does the judge never bought into
the government's case that they were
going to actually commit crimes but some
people
actually have been prosecuted and
convicted of sedition for example sheik
omar abdel rahman
a blind egyptian cleric living in new
jersey who is now serving a life
sentence in prison
rahman and nine other men were convicted
of seditious conspiracy despite
committing no
overt acts of war however ramen was
found to have encouraged the men to levy
war against the united states the group
was arrested while mixing explosives in
a garage in
queens the sedition laws make speech
criminal
only when the speech constitutes an
agreement to use force against the
united states
so in case you currently live in
michigan or let's be honest florida
here's how that would play out you can
generally give an opinion that the
government should be overthrown even by
violence
you can advocate for the forcible
overthrow of the government in the
abstract
but you can't explicitly encourage or
induce someone to overthrow the
government by
concrete action and it's not easy to
tell when speech plus action crosses
these lines
but to be convicted of seditious
conspiracy under section 2384
a defendant has to conspire to use force
not just advocate the use of force
so with that background let's look at
some of the things that president trump
and his surrogates have said all of the
beautiful conversations that they've had
that were 100 percent perfect
well during the first debate president
trump said that the right-wing
proud boy group should stand back and
stand by
boys stand back and stand by some of the
proud boys
viewed this comment as a call to action
according to extremist researchers
the proud boys went on a rampage in dc
early in december clashing with other
protesters resulting in several people
being stabbed
did president trump act like sheikh
rahman no
not quite were president trump's words
seditious
almost certainly not he was talking in
the abstract and while we may hate that
speech
under the first amendment we have to
live with it and that's probably the
better way
but let's talk about militias when a
group of private citizens gets together
to talk about hating the government
and that group is armed they're often
called militias but it's not illegal to
create a social group like this or even
for them to call themselves militias
however every state makes it illegal for
private militias to engage in activities
traditionally reserved for
authorized state militias and frankly
states are pretty lacks in actually
enforcing those laws which arguably
leads to more paranoid people gathering
with their guns and declaring themselves
as militias
this might be harmless but the fact that
there are prominent people encouraging
this kind of activity certainly doesn't
help
and the people arrested in michigan for
trying to kidnap the governor
were charged with violating michigan's
anti-terrorism statute rather than with
sedition
this is probably because sedition's
close association with speech
makes it really hard to prove so you
start to get the picture prosecutors
don't even like to charge
sedition because there are other
statutes that are a better fit and don't
have the sort of issues that you run
into with the first amendment
so you can see that charges of sedition
are incredibly rare and probably for
good reason
often not even being used against things
as extreme as an actual militia
so things like filing a bogus lawsuit to
overturn an election
not even going to come close to
actionable sedition though there are
ways that we might be able to punish
meritless lawsuits in different ways and
similarly challenging the electoral
college results through objections on
january 6th
is not sedition because congress people
are simply following a constitutional
mechanism
or at least what they vehemently and
wrongly believe those constitutional
mechanisms to be
now many of the capital rioters are
already being charged with seditious
conspiracy this is covered by 18 usc
2384.
the law gives prosecutors a variety of
ways to charge these writers for example
if two or more people conspire to
prevent hinder or delay the execution of
any law such as trying to stop congress
from tabulating the electoral college
votes
this could be seditious conspiracy i've
covered this extensively in another
video about all the crimes the capital
rioters committed
and likewise if two or more people quote
seize take or possess
any property of the united states such
as say stealing mail computers gavels
lecterns and other objects from the
capital
they could be charged under section 2384
in addition to being charged with
federal theft and vandalism
crimes now rioters can argue that they
were there to peacefully protest and
loudly expressing one's opinion is
protected under the first amendment even
if a person
generally advocates for the use of force
there is a first amendment right to
protest but there's not a first
amendment right to stop the government
from functioning so if prosecutors can
show that they were engaged in action
not just
speech they can probably prove sedition
and there's plenty of evidence of
coordination between members of this mob
but what about members of congress and
members of the president's inner circle
can they face charges for the
encouragement and participation
of what happened on january 6th well the
answer is that it both depends
and it's complicated an answer that i'm
sure will thrill absolutely everyone
now to prove seditious conspiracy there
must be an agreement between two or more
people who are working together towards
a common goal but the goal doesn't need
to be specifically articulated or
explicit
this means that the co-conspirators
didn't need to pinky swear that they
were going to barge into the capitol
building steal things threaten people
and beat up the cops
individual defendants can tacitly agree
to a larger conspiracy if they knew or
should have known that others were going
to take the same actions such as
storming the capitol building
and it's worth remembering why riders
stormed the building in the first place
they had the common goal of preventing
hindering or
delaying congress's counting and
certification of the electoral votes
and it also seems like they wanted to
punish mike pence and nancy pelosi and
anyone that they could get their hands
on
and while i wouldn't call it
overwhelming evidence there is certainly
some evidence of coordination with
people
fairly high up in the government for
example president trump promoted the
event and may have even met with the
leader of the proud boys on december
12th
the day after the supreme court
dismissed the texas lawsuit to overturn
the election
enrique tario the leader of the proud
boys posted on parlor
last minute invite to an undisclosed
location wow i'm
in awe and he was at the entrance to the
white house
tario's second post shows the main
portico with a comment never thought i'd
be here
and while the white house said that
tario was just taking a public tour it
didn't provide any proof that tario
followed the rules for white house
visits which require applying at least
21 days in advance and passing a
background check
tario is a convicted felon and we now
know that his group the proud boys
participated in the january 6th
attack and not surprisingly one of them
has been accused of plotting to kill
nancy pelosi and mike pence
and much of what we know about the plot
to overthrow the government is from
ollie alexander a right-wing conspiracy
theorist who led one of these stop the
steel groups
and in a live stream video after the
january 6th attack alexander said he
planned the rally with three gop
representatives paul goser and annie
biggs of arizona
and mo brooks of alabama i was the
person who came up with the january 6th
idea with congressman gosar congressman
mo brooks and then congressman andy
biggs
and this wasn't something that alexander
came up with after the fact the
intercept reported that alexander
claimed to be working with members of
congress
three times before the rally happened on
december 21st 28th and 29th
now remember that because we'll get back
to that in just a second but let's talk
about the element of force
seditious conspiracy requires that
co-conspirators plan to effectuate their
illegal ends by some
unlawful means co-conspirators need to
have considered the use of force even
though the ultimate gold need not
actually use force
and the element of force does not
necessarily mean engaging in explicitly
violent activities
the government can prove this element if
the co-conspirators contemplated the
unlawful invasion
of rights of others and in media
appearances before the event alexander
raised the stakes and predicted violence
he first asserted that if biden's win
was certified
there would be slavery concentration
camps serfdom and
death if you do not stand up and fight
now you are
signing your road and your ticket to
serfdom
alexander was very clear about what he
intended to do on january 6 to stop this
from happening
quote everyone can guess what me and 500
000 others will do
to that building 1776 is always an
option
and on january 5th alexander led trump
supporters in a peaceful rally on
freedom plaza where he shouted
victory or death victory
alexander's claims sound far-fetched but
there are many links between alexander
and prominent republicans
the arizona republican party endorsed a
message from alexander that he was
willing to die for donald trump
saying are you it asked of supporters so
let's come back to the three stooges
starting with paul gosar
arizona rep gosar did not say anything
to contradict the official arizona
position on dying for donald trump
gosar was in close contact with
alexander though and according to
alexander gosar helped him raise money
for various rallies
gosar confirmed alexander's claim that
he helped organize the rallies
quote i helped organize the very first
stop the steel rally in arizona
patriotic warriors joined together to
gather evidence and tell the left
that we will not accept a coup and a
usurper in the white house
he spent basically all of december
railing against the election result and
appearing with alexander
at rallies in an opinion piece published
on december 7th not coincidentally the
anniversary of the bombing of pearl
harbor
gosar described the election of joe
biden as a coup
be ready to defend the constitution and
the white house
gosar described alexander as a true
patriot and linked to alexander's
account at least 23 times since november
30th 2020.
here's gosar and alexander together at a
stop to steal rally in arizona on
december 19th
gosar was present when alexander said
we're going to convince them to not
certify the vote on january 6 by
marching hundreds of thousands if not
millions of patriots
to sit their butts in dc and close that
city down right
and if we have to explore other options
after that yet
yet it seems clear in context that these
other options contemplated the use of
force and
three days later on december 22nd gosar
met with president trump along with
brooks
biggs and others he tweeted that biden
had committed sedition
and that he could never quote accept
disenfranchisement of those who voted
for trump
this sedition will be stopped and at
1205 pm
on the day of the capital riots gosar
tweeted that biden should concede
i want his concession on my desk
tomorrow morning don't make me come
over there is this a threat of force it
probably depends because it always
depends we'd also say that the sentence
don't make me come over there is just
gosar saying he's going to
vote to overturn the election during the
attack gosar used his twitter account to
call for peaceful protests but
used his parlor account to share a
picture of rioters climbing the walls
americans are upset he said these words
don't quite condone violence but they do
imply that gosar is on their side and
gosar's own brother and other members of
his family condemn him as a propagandist
who committed sedition and treason
and they asked that he'd be removed from
congress
you're just as guilty as the mob that
you
beseeched and took and um
overran the house
and that takes us to stooge number two
mo brooks
alexander also said he worked with
alabama representative mo brooks
brooks was the first person to announce
that he would challenge the electoral
college when congress met to count the
votes on january 6th
i have a choice i can either sit back
and surrender
and be a part of the surrender caucus or
i can fight for our country
brooks rallied support for this maneuver
and the process of challenging the
electoral college is spelled out in the
constitution so
that's not a crime however brooks knew
that this challenge would fail because
there would not be enough people in the
house who would vote to overturn the
election
but nevertheless brooks appeared at the
rally where he spoke directly to the
writers who would later storm the
capital
did he contemplate the use of force
today
is the day american patrons start taking
down names
and kicking ass
now our ancestors sacrificed their blood
their sweat their tears their fortunes
and sometimes their lives
to give us their descendants an america
that is the greatest nation in world
history
so i have a question for you
are you willing to do the same
answer is yes louder are you willing to
do what it takes
to fight for america
louder will you fight for america
now brooks doesn't say fight comps or
trespass or kill but
what is he asking people to do in this
context it seems like spill
blood like their ancestors now these
words might be considered hyperbole
which is
protected speech but the problem with
brooks's words is that he was telling
people to fight for an outcome that he
already knew
couldn't happen and that directly
incited people going to the capitol and
storming it and speaking of advocating
for violence let's talk about don jr
and rudy during the january 6th event
many speakers used incendiary language
and encouraged the crowd to fight
these words included specific references
to members of congress
donald trump jr targeted congress
members who were not willing to object
to certification saying
if you're gonna be the zero and not the
hero
we're coming for you and we're gonna
have a good time doing it
does this contemplate the use of force
well in comparison rudy giuliani
proposed
quote trial by combat let's have trial
by
combat and actively sought to delay
certification of the election
and giuliani who's famous for not
actually knowing how to use a cell phone
left a phone message
meant for alabama senator tuberville
saying that they needed a reason to
delay the vote so that they could
present evidence of voter fraud the next
day
i'm calling you because i want to
discuss with you how they're trying to
rush this hearing
and how we need you our republican
friends
to try to just slow it down so we can
get these legislators to get
more information to you but the only
strategy we can follow
is to object to numerous states
and raise issues so that we get
ourselves into tomorrow
ideally until the end of tomorrow at
this point rudy knew that the vote would
be confirmed by the house and senate
he knew there was no place left to
present voter fraud claims he had
pressed his claims in court
in ad hoc meetings with rogue
legislators around the country and at a
lawn care company in philadelphia
now a prosecutor could ask a jury to
infer that rudy had no intention of
presenting new evidence of voter fraud
on january 7th and
that in fact rudy was actually aware of
and encouraging trump's followers to
storm the capital to stop the voters we
put it
get ourselves into tomorrow crew
citizens for responsibility and ethics
in washington
characterized this as evidence that
trump and his associates were engaged in
a conspiracy with a common goal of
preventing hindering or delaying
congress's counting
and certification of the electoral votes
cast in the 2020 presidential election
now we don't know whether trump jr or
rudy had direct contacts with
riders however don jr's girlfriend
kimberly guilfoyle allegedly spoke with
alexander on january 5th
informing him that trump was in quote
fighter mode
and by the way people are asking a lot
of great questions about the legal
issues that are happening in washington
dc these days so there are a lot more
legal eagles but only a small percentage
of the people that watch these videos
are actually subscribed
so if you enjoy this analysis please hit
subscribe
but back to ali alexander and all of the
connections he had to various
representatives
one of those representatives is marjorie
taylor greene who is
a famous cue a non-believer alexander
responded to one of her tweets by
claiming that congress was trying to
stop objections to the electoral vote
alexander's response was
about 1776. if they do this everyone can
guess what me and 500 000 others will do
to that building
alexander tweeted on december 30th 1776
is always an option
and marjorie taylor green tweeted 1776
on the day of the attack
could we argue that green was attempting
to aid the rioters or even overthrow the
government
possibly it always depends and it's
always complicated
though green already has a history of
threatening violence in a facebook post
from 2018 green wrote that house speaker
nancy pelosi was guilty of treason
green argued that pelosi should be
executed when pelosi came out against
trump's border wall
greene made a second facebook post
claiming that pelosi committed treason
which she pointed out is quote a crime
punishable by
death now these tweets alone are
incredibly unlikely to give rise to
any kind of sedition indictment for a
tweet to be
actionable you'd need much more than
that you'd need a direct link between
the
representative tweeting it and
potentially aiding
the capital writers something like what
lauren bobert did
republican representative lauren bobert
of colorado tweeted nancy pelosi's
whereabouts
while the attack unfolded bobert is also
affiliated with a q a non-conspiracy
movement to
the surprise of absolutely no one and
during the attack bobert tweeted that
pelosi had been quote removed from the
house
chambers while rioters were still in the
building
bobert did not say where pelosi was but
rioters did make it into pelosi's office
this tweet was so ill-advised and the
strategic value
to someone who is looking for nancy
pelosi to
kidnap and potentially kill her given
that it was so
obvious some wonder if bobert actually
intended for this tweet
to be public or if she meant to send it
privately to someone else
but if the intent is there if she did
intend this tweet to aid
the capital rioters to actually kidnap
and potentially harm nancy pelosi
even if it didn't actually happen that
certainly could give rise to
a sedition claim so finally that takes
us to the tweedledee and tweedledum of
this whole election objection affair
the kings of this confederacy of dunces
i'm of course talking about senators ted
cruz
and josh
absolutely i think we're hawley members
of congress swear an oath to protect and
defend the constitution which
establishes a republican form of
government
and unfortunately many republican
lawmakers made repeated
false allegations about the elections
filed many
meritless lawsuits or at least
encouraged those meritless lawsuits
and of course filed objections to the
election in congress itself
and in the senate hawley struck first
claiming that he was speaking for all of
trump's voters in vowing to object to
the election results
ted cruz formulated a similar response
but with a twist
cruz proposed a 10-day investigation
into voter fraud before certifying the
electoral college result
the reason cruz and hawley's actions
struck a nerve is because
they were both ivy league trained
lawyers who obviously know their legal
claims have no validity in law
the constitution doesn't allow for a
delay in the inauguration which has to
happen on january 20th at noon
and after the attack cruz and hawley did
not back down
their hometown newspapers even called
for holly and cruz to resign or be
expelled
from congress now in fairness and i
realize this is an incredibly low bar
but it seems that
neither holly nor cruz ever advocated
the use of violence to overturn the
election
so let's assume that sedition and
treason are out the window
is there anything else that can be done
to punish holly and cruz
for their despicable behavior with
respect to the election
well a lot of people have been talking
about expulsion
and expulsion is a thing that congress
can do expulsion is the process by which
a house of congress may remove one of
its members
after the member has been duly elected
and seated there are two sections of the
constitution which authorize expulsion
article 1 section 5 clause 2 states each
house may determine the rules of its
proceedings
punish its members for disorderly
behavior and with a concurrence of
two-thirds expel a member
the expulsion clause is interpreted
broadly giving each house of congress
significant discretion to
decide the grounds for expelling their
members courts give congress wide
latitude to make their own rules
and as a result courts generally have
declined to adjudicate the standards by
which
the house and senate have fashion to
deal with their colleagues
but historically 20 members of congress
have been expelled without being
convicted of crimes in a court of law
five in the house and 15 in the senate
now most of those expulsions dealt with
actions taken
leading up to the civil war but more
recent expulsions dealt with members of
congress who had been convicted of
public corruption
so there's actually precedent for
expelling members for being disloyal to
the united states and by the way
the history of congress expelling its
own members is
fascinating i don't have the time or
inclination to go over it right now
because i'm already losing my grip on
sanity because of this over long video
but i'd highly recommend you check out
my friends at the podcast opening
arguments they did an entire episode on
congress expelling its own members and
it's really really incredibly
interesting and speaking about the
aftermath of the civil war
a lot of people have been talking about
the 14th amendment as well and
specifically section 3 of the 14th
amendment says that
no person shall be a senator or
representative in congress or
elector of the president and vice
president or hold any office
who shall have engaged in insurrection
or rebellion against the same
and give an aid or comfort to the
enemies thereof
but congress may buy a vote of
two-thirds of each house remove
such disability so to the extent that
any of these members of congress
are actually adjudicated to have
committed the crime of sedition
arguably a reading of the 14th amendment
says that they cannot serve
in that house of congress anymore but i
think we can all agree now that q on has
been proven again to be an insanely
stupid conspiracy theory that
everyone that participated in the riots
should be out of a job and hopefully
even the politicians but they could all
benefit from
emma gannon's skillshare class
discovering success seven exercises to
uncover your purpose
passion and path they'll need a new
business and a new passion because
they're cute on purpose
was a lie and since they were all dumb
enough to livestream themselves storming
the capital i know for a fact that
they're dumb and can't shoot selfies for
anything so they'd also benefit from
jessica kobey's skillshare class
portrait photography
shoot and edit instagram worthy shots
because the stuff that was on instagram
deserves to be in jail skillshare as i'm
sure you know is one of the world's
largest online
learning communities and has tens of
thousands of classes on everything like
business creative writing music and
productivity everything the ex-q and
cult member needs
and the first 1 000 legal eagles will
get a free trial of skillshare premium
when you click on the link in the
description and you can watch all of the
videos
plus after the trial ends skillshare is
still way more affordable than most
online learning platforms with plans
starting at just 10
per month so just click on the link
below in the description and get a free
trial membership of skillshare
plus clicking on that link in the
description really helps out this
channel
but do you agree with my analysis leave
your objections in the comments which i
will either sustain or overrule and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my other real law reviews where i
tackle the legal issues
of the day from this friggin
administration
and as always i'll see you in court